[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
sex for a long time I'm link and I'm sex
I mean Rhett
this week at the round table of dim
lighting We are continuing on with
September
probably the last
insects Timber and instead of getting
professionals uh to give us solid
evidence-based information now we're
turning back to us just the two guys who
make this podcast we're also turning to
you though we ask you if you had a
burning sex related question I don't
think that was a gonorrhea reference
right but well it could be or a
hilarious sex-related story we said we
wanted to discuss it on here biscuits
discuss it we said you could call us at
188 earpod one you could email us we
made an address so it could be anonymous
we're not going to mention any names
today and Jenna if you're willing we
want you to read the anonymous emails so
that we could have the sense of it being
a voicemail
even though it's just we all know it's
just you happy happy to read them for
everyone yeah she's happy happy are you
going to do voices or are you going to
do Jenna voice uh Jenna voice
you can change your mind it's up to you
we'll see you when we get to it it's up
to you
um
do we need any preambles of course just
the warning of this is
more specific and potentially explicit
sexy sexy sex conversation so if this
isn't for you or any other ears who may
be earshot
skip it or put some earbuds in I would
say that I have seen and appreciated a
lot of the support that we've gotten for
going back into sex Timber again and
talking about these things candidly uh I
got very little if any butt plug shaming
thus far just a couple of jokes here and
there maybe
um oh yeah no shaming so yeah I just you
know we've got a great herd of mythical
beasts that they're happy that we're
talking about sex again I do think that
they're happy that we we brought in some
qualified professionals so today is our
happy ending exactly of this series I uh
I'll tell you what I haven't received
any butt plugs well you know like uh
Emily was supposed to send us well
shipping I mean she's going to send them
I mean it hasn't been that long
you know do I need to resort to to my
own ordering devices
well first of all yes you can do your
own sex toy ordering that is completely
up to you but I'm saying I don't want to
be just inundated with uh butt plugs if
I'm gonna get them from two different
angles well you know you kind of only
want one angle at a time if you get too
many butt plugs you can give them out
for like Christmas gifts I never knew
your extended family would appreciate
that butt plug thing would be such a
Cornerstone part of this sex Timber well
they make quite a stocking stuffer
is that what you call it you're stalking
what is that a turnip
a Mario
Mario turnip yeah yeah all right
let's play one first I I mean maybe they
didn't say their name I guess we can
bleep it but we're not we're not going
to disguise voices yeah yeah yeah all
right let's play the first voicemail hey
Rhett and Link this is in regards to
your uh rated R question that you posted
on Twitter just today on whatever today
was
yeah
um my question to you is if you could
suck your own joint would you go
I was asked this question at my old job
and they were very non-discriminate
about who they asked it to
pretty pretty open about it so I was
wondering if you guys would be that way
too have a great one so it's an
interview question they had this
particular indiscriminately asked this
question at his former place of
employment would you suck your own joint
I'm just imagining it's a Subway I don't
know why I don't I mean I I just I just
was imagining that question being asked
openly by sandwich artists while there's
a line of people waiting to order the uh
extra mayo low-fat Mayo don't do the
low-fat Mayo
um second of all the term joint for
penis had heard him but I don't dislike
it yeah uh I I knew immediately what he
was talking about yeah because it would
suck your own
was the first was the preamble to join
it right yeah I don't know but I mean
you could suck any joint like you people
try to lick their own elbow
but yeah some people can can
successfully
um well I don't know how to answer this
other than I've tried
I mean yeah I've tried to I mean who
I've who has stride the people who have
I mean it it kind of uh you know once
you discover masturbation it's it's
pretty much like doesn't that seem like
the next level yeah it's like I can I
it's like this hand is really well
equipped and to do a lot of great things
it just dangles right down there next to
it what can this thing do I'm pointing
in my mouth
um
if you can't reach it I'm not as
flexible as I used to be
uh but I'll just go on record and say
that I believe probably around age I was
at my
sexual peak and sexual limberness at
probably like 16.
you know and I'm and I do remember uh
it's funny how I feel like I always end
up saying something really
self-disclosing and potentially
embarrassing really early in these
episodes yeah and then because you do I
don't feel the need to say anything okay
well because I don't want it to seem
like I'm trying to outdo you or compare
myself to you because I think it's
important that yours your sexual
experience is your own and it's not
about comparing so I think sometimes
when somebody asks you if you accept
your own joint you got to answer I said
that I've tried and now you're about to
say something else but I just want to
say maybe you're a little disappointed
that I haven't had as much disclosure
this month no no no no as as you have no
I wasn't saying it as opposed to you I
was just saying it's just funny how it
just ends up happening in these first
questions
uh I did make
um
how can I say
I did at one point make tongue tube tip
contacts but it hurt really bad like but
I was your back was so uncomfortable
that and I I mean I there was nothing
else could happen it was just like they
touched in a moment of
Discovery and Beauty I'm sure it was not
beautiful to look at it's kind of like
those those angel babies and the Sistine
Chapel like their finger tips like
reaching out to each other no that's God
man
that's the hand of God and I don't know
in this scenario or this dick is God I
thought it was angel babies I think it's
no angel baby's reaching out well yeah
but one of the hands is God oh and the
other one's a baby uh I don't know what
the other hand is yeah but one of them's
God's hands yeah one of these in this
yeah analogously is
our tongue if you could suck your
Collective if you could suck your own
God's hand
I'm sorry I didn't mean to get
sacrilegious
yeah don't do that I wasn't talking
about your God I was just talking about
okay an artist somebody else's attention
of almost touching
so anyway uh telling the tip contact is
the best I ever did yeah because you're
you're bent over so far especially with
your back I was thinking that maybe you
had more success I remember my back was
bent over so far you're so flexible like
it
um it was hurting so bad that like it
started you know it created a retreat
scenario for my member I was joint
asking you my college I was on my back
oh you were doing like a backwards it
was all on my back and I was folding
myself over well listen
around I guess this was high school when
that Tool album came out and when you
opened it up there was a picture and I
swear I don't know I I hope this isn't
just something that I created in my head
that you could move it and it had that
like it was two images with the viewing
angle thing and like so it would have an
animation and it was a guy
you pleasuring himself with his yeah he
was doing just this
and he was shirtless yeah and his back
was to the camera and he was like I just
thought he was like waddling back and
forth and then I realized that no no no
this guy's achieved something that
requires circus level flexibility I I
just gotta can I try this and then it
hurt too bad right if it was easy like
if if my penis was my thumb I probably
wouldn't have a job you know what I'm
saying I I'd be like a baby I'd be like
a baby I mean I'm just gonna tell you
right now if I could I would and if it
was easy I would be doing it all the
time if it was I'm glad that it's hard
if it was easy everybody would be doing
it right nothing it doesn't apply to
this
any lesson any other scenario we're
speaking of God there's a reason that
she didn't put the penis uh on the thumb
because she knew that we would all be
you know sucking our thumbs all the time
I mean I actually think that's what
determines the length of your penis you
know so it can you know if you think
that like longer's better and maybe
you're self-conscious about like the
the length or of it
then you just say you know what it
there's it's a formula if it was too
long you'd be in trouble right if it's
too long you wouldn't have a job if it
was too long you wouldn't have a job
right
I mean I
yeah is there anything else to say about
this I think we've said quite a bit
Let's uh let's get a story here I'm
gonna click on this voicemail hey this
is Morgan Womack I wanted to uh
um tell you about a sex related story
and I really don't care if you keep it
Anonymous or not because all everybody
knows this at this point everybody I
know anyway so when I was younger and I
was dating my boyfriend I skipped school
and went over to his house and being the
teenagers that we were we ended up uh in
the bedroom
well his mom was not supposed to come
home from work until like 5 PM
but when we were in the middle of uh
yeah
uh I hear high heels clicking on the
wooden floor outside of his door his mom
slammed open his door and started
lecturing us going off on us both of us
are Buck ass naked in bed freaking out
I'm crying I had brought my iPod over to
my boyfriend's house
it was set on shuffle while his mother
was lecturing us about our horrible
choices the song Pour Some Sugar On Me
by Def Leppard started playing on the
iPod and it was across the room we could
not turn it off so she lectured us to
the soundtrack before Some Sugar On Me
my husband and I cut our wedding cake to
that song
together all these years later so that's
my funny story
and I'll never live it down I still have
friends to this day call me
when that song's on the radio just so I
can hear it
what yeah you guys have a good day bye
well we are now Morgan Morgan Morgan
listen did Morgan say that they got
married
yes like so there you go mom you were
wrong
sleep inside Walk This Way have sex in
front of your mom hey hey well you
didn't talk about was uh what happened
when they were caught because I I've
never been caught having sex
by anybody and I don't really know what
the plan is here but I I think that if
you're okay
let's just go I'm gonna give you a
scenario what I think you should do if
you're
um
having sex with someone at their house
like they're like they're you know in
their parents they live with their
parents and their parents catch you
having sex with their child
their daughter or son whatever I mean
yes you know I'm tracking then
I you have to stop having sex first of
all let's just let's just say you do not
finish
once you're caught you do not finish I
think that's one rule but then I think
you don't don't run out I think you
stand up and introduce yourself
I think you extend your hand if you made
your bed lie in it but you made your
decision Stand Up and Shake sir it's
nice to meet you
you know you go and you give a nice firm
handshake don't jump out the window
don't go into the closet because you you
are still making your first impression
in that moment and it's like well you
know what he snuck in here he had sex
with her daughter but uh he gave me a
nice firm handshake you know
I wouldn't touch any fist bump
like what about just like a nice
assertive wave
like point and snap hey just a little
wave I'm not don't touch I don't want to
be touched
yeah that's true I didn't think about
that yeah no physical contact with fist
buff is okay with the parental figure
unless you've been fisting I mean I
would that point
then it could be a rush I
listen I'd be in that closet before with
two clicks of the you go in the closet
they it's you can't it's like an ostrich
putting his head in the sand you're
still in the closet
you just can't go in the closet yeah it
just makes it you gotta just take it and
be like I mean at least you could then
grab something out of the closet put it
on and come out and I do think putting
up maybe putting up some sort of like I
in fact you got a sheet quickly apply it
like a toga and then you just look like
a history buff oh we were you know we
were actually doing our Greek homework
yeah that's right this is role play
yeah it is
we were in we were in the bath the Roman
bath there's no penetration
what do you mean there's no penetration
in the Roman bath no no I'm just saying
I'm going along with it I'm saying you
got to say you got to tell appearance
there's no penetration I mean I've as
I've established I've been seen
through a window
by hikers but I've never been caught by
someone I knew
I've almost been caught by
um
a child who just came in you got to make
sure that door's locked well put
yourself in this in the shoes of a
parent and let's say you come home and
you find one of your children
having lovey time with a significant
other
yeah what what are you going to do in
that moment what would you do
um
I would I would I would not I well I try
not to burst into doors and catch people
do kids doing anything true but let's
just say accidentally you knocked you
didn't I would immediately I'd
immediately leave and I would say let's
discuss this later discuss this later
that's that's the the funny part of the
story is that
you gotta like
obviously they're probably not going to
finish after they've been caught like
you you mission accomplished you stop
them from having sex whatever you close
a door
and then you just go and sit in a living
room
and just wait I would take a jog
probably well I would like yeah but you
don't lecture them I do have a punching
bag in my in my garage that Christy got
years ago when's the last time you
punched that thing
um I've never punched it but I think
this would be the perfect occasion yeah
so that's where I'll be
I'll be out there just punching the
Daylights out of that thing
okay and just trying to figure out how
I'm going to keep my cool
afterwards but also it's a natural
process what was happening I you hope
that it's happening in a way that is
responsible and I think that's that's
the that's the way you want to have the
conversation it's because it sounds like
in this scenario maybe Morgan's parents
didn't know that she was having sex yet
or whatever you know yeah but if you're
like oh my kids are sexually active you
know in a relationship or whatever and
you know that they're having sex and
catching them having sex is kind of a is
different
then this being your
you know realization that your kids are
having sex right
it's it's so difficult to
decide to start talking openly about sex
especially with like your first child
you know if you have multiple children
um because it it
unless you unless you're in like a
really open household where you just
discuss all these things and like you
make sex references all the time even
before your kid can understand what
they're talking about so they never can
remember a moment when you weren't
making some sort of sexual reference
just kind of like oh I remember watching
this sitcom for years and then I I got
to an age where I realized that they've
been making sexual references the whole
time that's kind of a nice way to just
kind of make it part of what you the the
the communication climate in the home
but practically speaking
for a lot of people including me that
never happens so it's like with the with
now that my kids are I have older kids
and younger kids there was a different
Dynamic of
you know you're referencing things and
we're making a decision to kind of like
the fact that sex exists and it is
that and they have an opportunity to do
it it's like we might as well it's it's
counterproductive to like never speak of
it and then the younger siblings they
just kind of get they kind of absorb it
in a way that inoculates you in a good
way to it being something we can never
talk about it's a taboo but with that
first child at least I'm oversimplifying
here you have to make this decision and
it's hard to not
do it too late
you know I think it's a little bit
a little bit goes a long way and it's
better to start a little early than too
late it helps when your kids are begging
you to tell them which is what happened
with yeah which we talked about last
time but yeah Morgan
uh sounds like it all worked out for you
yeah congrats on the marriage Jenna
let's get to an anonymous email
would you like a question or story first
let's go question okay
uh
doesn't like sex how can I spice it up
hello long time fan first time emailer
okay I have a sex related question that
might be TMI I've been with my husband
for seven whole years and while I hate
to admit it our sex life is boring sad
predictable I even once told him to
please don't love me in the bedroom
do you guys have suggestions how to
spice it up or just how to initiate that
uncomfortable conversation P.S we're
both huge fans all the best I asked my
husband to love me everywhere but the
bedroom
please don't love me in the bedroom is
so first stop saying that
[Music]
what yeah that one I guess I guess what
they're getting at is you know foreplay
starts out of the bedroom
that's not what I heard what did you
hear I wanna they wanna have sex
somewhere else like not in the bedroom
no I heard that they are not having a
very active sex life I heard that too
um and for for whatever reason
and but the thing is seven years is that
it sounds like there is a desire to have
a more active sex life and maybe they're
both on team let's have more sex and
let's have a more satisfying sex life I
think one of the things that we learn in
talking to the Dr Emily's doctor is
Emily right uh that's when you say
Attorneys General that's how you say it
right you know the doctors Emily is um
that
it's and I and I have a tendency to do
this I have a tendency to normalize my
situation and my behavior and then sort
of say that this is what the way that it
should be for other people and I'm as I
get older I'm learning to do that lesson
lesson one of the things that they both
hinted at was
this idea that there's not a normal
amount of sex or whatever but
if you are both on team let's have more
sex
that's a good start right because that's
that's a place that you're like oh we're
not as satisfied as we would like to be
so because you got to communicate to
some point where where you where you can
get on the same page to know what the
next step is and then if you're on that
page then okay well what does that look
like how do you spice it up how do you
have more sex how do you have love me in
the bedroom time that's kind of what I
was hearing there I yeah I think the
best advice here is you know get to Come
As You Are book read it together discuss
it I mean there's even a workbook if
you're into that I I just think that
that will go a long way as I was reading
it in preparation for our last
conversation
Christy re-read it she had already read
it years ago and I never read it because
as with a lot of books she's like really
into
um the non-fiction self-help reference
material type stuff of what whatever
she's into at the time
um and she'll always say I want you to
read this and you know what I never do
it I just say just tell me about it just
tell me about it give me the blink
version just give me the let's give me
the active sex version of you like you
read it Mal just show me yeah what do
you want me to do visual aids welcome
right
um but reading it
separately but then talking about it
together was really beneficial and it it
it it'll get you more horny giving you a
giving yourself a structure and
especially one that is specifically
designed to talk about sex and to talk
about right maybe you're not informed
about from a professional standpoint
I completely agree and it doesn't have
that's a great that's a great book but
there's also other books and I'm sure
there might even be books that I don't
know about that are designed for people
in this exact situation just you know
Google book for a couple that wants to
have more sex whatever uh I in fact I
think that um I think that Emily has a
Emily Morris Dr Emily Morris has a book
about like 200 things you can do tonight
right yeah and it's a lot in one night
yeah and then Dr nagoski is coming out
with a new book as well right about
keeping things fun for long-term
relationships there's so many different
things out there so don't don't fear
don't don't feel don't feel weird about
it but um just discuss it and making it
make it into a little happy project yeah
Play Pour Some Sugar On Me see what
happens when you do that in the bedroom
or just Pour Some Sugar on you know what
I've never done that see what happens
just straight sugar straight sugar
all right voicemail hi Rhett and Link
love you guys so much my name is Sarah
I'm just curious I was such a fan of
success last year and
I know Rhett and Link both of you guys
but I feel like I heard it more from
Rhett address the issue of vibrators in
the bedroom and I am a young woman and I
would love to use one in the bedroom and
I'm just curious how you think a woman
should approach
that subject with their man
how to introduce that
you know I feel like some men might be
opposed to it but I think a woman might
very much enjoy it as I would too but
thank you so much if you answer this I
love you guys have a great day all right
we are going to answer it so she's gonna
love us
I you know what I actually think that my
guess is that many fewer men than you
would think are actually
like uh threatened by a vibrator I think
that most guys are turned on by it again
I'm speaking for most people at this
point and maybe I'm making a mistake
here I'm just saying that as somebody
who likes to think that I can get the
job done and I'm proud of myself in that
area
I don't I don't see a vibrator as a
threat I see it as just a little a
little sexy twist you know uh and also
you know I'm into modern technology
yeah you know I mean the fact that we
what a time to be alive you know that
these things can exist
and sometimes they can really just get
the job done
I think using a vibrator on your own is
can be a very viable way to figure out
what works for you
and then if that's why you want to bring
it in there because it's like hey this
this can help
us this can help me when we're together
you know and then your partner can learn
from it I mean it it's a great thing I'm
a fan of the vibrator being a part of
the uh Excursion
oh yeah
um because it it just helps you know and
you can use them at the same time you
can use a vibrator which or your partner
she can use a vibrator and then you're
still uh penetrating so like both it's
it's a two for one and if you're worried
about if you're worried about the
first of all I just think the simplest
way is just to be like hey ask the
question how would you feel about it and
I think you might be surprised by the
answer but I think that's hot is what I
think most guys would say but if you're
worried about that here's one way you
could do it um
take I'm holding a giant vibrator take a
take a vibrator
uh take a toothbrush
uh cut the head off of the toothbrush
glue the toothbrush part
to the vibrator and then just start
using it as a toothbrush for I'd say
four to six weeks and he'll be like
that's one hell of a vibrating
toothbrush you'd be like yeah it's a new
thing new tech from Colgate I don't know
just throw a brand in there makes it
seem legitimate Oral B
and you you hold it like it's going to
be different oral D yeah it's gonna be
different than those ones but then he'll
just it's like when you're trying to get
a dog to be like accustomed to the crate
that they're eventually going to be in
first thing you do is you just set it in
the room
and then they're like okay this thing's
not a threat maybe I'll get in there one
day you gotta slowly get a man you have
to treat a man like an animal sometimes
yeah and you just let him know this
thing's not a threat that giant pink
toothbrush that she's been enjoying for
the past six weeks is not a threat next
thing you know she's got it in the bed
and he's like oh brushing your teeth
early and no and then you just
demonstrate what else you can do with it
and I think he'll be he'll go along with
it
yeah uh if it's not about the threat but
it's just about this feels weird
um maybe you're maybe there's like a
grounded version of that advice that
actually works because I do there's
truth in what you're saying it's like
you you find a way to ease into it
I don't know exactly what that is but
because for us we talked about last last
year
we both you and I went and bought the
same vibrator no we both bought the same
model of Library the green world but we
each had our own we didn't like have to
loan it out no you shouldn't do that
like like don't share have a sign up
sheet
um and then remember I put I put the
mask on Christy and then I I I broke it
out and just
started poking her around around
different places
I surprised her with it in different not
just
um down there but yeah under the arms
just like it was it was just like it was
just a fun little playful thing but like
I did spring it on her and I I don't
quite recommend that
but it was my idea and it was just like
hey I got and I did say I got I got
something maybe yeah just one one idea
I'm trying to develop some freaking
advice here oh I'm trying to land on
something
take a playful approach in a neutral
setting where you can have a
conversation about it and you can make
it a little sexy it's like
I had this idea what if
what if we um
use a use the vibrator next time we uh
have sex
just think about it
just giving just just give him a Beat
Just logging it just just think about it
it's just an idea something just
something to make more fun for both of
us let's make more fun together you ever
touched yourself with a vibrator uh yeah
it doesn't quite do it's a little yeah
it can be a little overwhelming but at
times
you know
and it's it's nice to have sex and have
your partner control the vibrator and
then it's like there's a communication
about like what's too much if it's like
if there's a couple of things going on
at once and then you knit like all right
let's reduce it to one thing at once and
then the other thing and you get to a
point where it's like because talking
about like I think it was mentioned over
the last two episodes well
masturbating in front of your partner
a mutual that seems masturbation I mean
when you just say it that seems so weird
but then really it it does as an idea as
an abstract idea it's like we're gonna
walk in this room and then we're gonna
each like pleasure ourselves
while we watch each other it's like
but practically speaking it's something
that can just find its way into
happening and then you find like oh this
is just another way that we can play
together
even though we're playing with ourselves
so it's it's not all this start let's
decide to do this it's more of like
let's have an attitude of play and an
openness to know what the what are the
what are the toys that we can use here
what are the what are the things we can
try and you just kind of keep an
open-ended and just make it a make it an
adventure and just see what happens and
try certain things some things don't
work you can kind of pull back you can
just take the battery sometimes and
sometimes you will you'll surprise
yourself when you're in the heat of
passion the things that you say and the
things that you do it's like that's part
of the fun of it is just like wow I'm
surp I I there's
I didn't even know I had this in me you
know it's there's like a release of not
just sexual tension
but also
personality
release your personality in the bedroom
yeah here's a story so I have an uh
embarrassing uh sex related story
um it was actually from when I lost my
virginity now it's most people this
might sound like a dream but it in fact
was not I've lost my virginity in a
threesome yes a threesome now what made
it so bad well let me tell you I really
didn't know what to do with my hands so
well the two lovely people that I was
also with were kind of going at it I was
going to sit there I just started doing
the Cha-Cha because I had no clue what
else to do and they looked at me I was
very embarrassed to the point where um
things went soft so yeah that's my sex
my sexy sexy embarrassing story
um yeah
um
oh my gosh
what is the Cha-Cha actually look like
is it like this
no it's footsteps it sounds like he was
standing up he was standing up yeah it's
like a little like forward and backwards
yeah forward and back kind of stepping
wow thanks for sharing
um but I do believe virginity was lost
and we didn't I don't believe well we
don't I don't believe opportunity to the
Cha-Cha I don't personally believe in
the loss of virginity I don't think
there is it we talked about this that's
true I don't believe that you have
something that you're losing sex was had
for the first time for the first time
during a threesome
wow that's bold that's both I've never I
mean you can Again In the Heat of
passion you can find yourself in
interesting situations and it's nice to
be able to access some sort of game game
plan the Cha-Cha call it your person
can't be the it can't be the awkward
cha-cha I mean I've never come anywhere
close to having a threesome you know as
we firmly established I've only had sex
with one personally Christy
um
but I don't you know it's oh man I don't
I yeah I don't I wouldn't know exactly
what you you know get in where you fit
in but that sometimes that's not obvious
I I now my assumption here is that the
people who were the other two members of
the threesome
probably did not realize that this
person had never had sex before
I'm not going to give advice much advice
about threesomes because I don't have
any experience but it just feels to me
like it would be a good guideline to be
like
um maybe that's not the best way for
someone to lose their virginity or
someone to have sex for the first time
in the context of a threesome uh that's
just you know especially it's not a good
multitasker like uninformed opinion it
feels like chapter two
at the earliest yeah talking about
jumping in the deep end
um wow that's uh
you know what I mean and again any a
little sense of humor goes a long way
I think
if you if you're doing the Cha-Cha and
they're kind of like
laughing it's just you know you're just
trying to own it well I have to assume
that that them looking at him doing the
Cha-Cha was the saying they were like oh
what do you want to would you like to be
a part of do you want us to dance as
well or would you like to do what we're
doing
and that was probably what proceeded to
the moment here's another question hey
Rhett and Link uh this is anonymous
people might have this question after
listening to your
sex besode that you just had and uh
coming from a similar background as
y'all with the charity culture
Evangelical upbringing I would be
curious to hear an expert talk perhaps
somebody that might know
boom and embarrassment around stamina
lasting law and whatnot so short of
taking the little blue pill I'm curious
uh if you all have experience with this
or if you have any experts you know that
could talk on this be blessed
um any experts in the room uh nope but
we can talk about stamina I mean stamina
is really built up as this thing of like
and I do feel this
um culturally not not in my specific
bedroom but culturally this pressure to
like you know to to go long and strong
and you when something is can be as fun
as sex it's like yeah you wanna you
wanna you wanna you don't wanna every
time be over with in a Flash yeah you
want to be able to draw out the
experience and
um but even
speaking specifically about like the old
in and out like you get to the actual
specific the in and out of sex and at a
certain point you'd like you'd like for
that particular action to be to go on
for a while but that's difficult to do
the thrusting is the old Cha-Cha is
difficult to maintain
I mean in in my experience you know you
get you so you find yourself mixing
things up it's like all right we're
gonna I'm gonna do that for a little
while and then I'm gonna do something
different that so you know we're still
very much much engaged
but it's like all right
so we you switch gears but also you
switch practices yeah right and you can
go back and forth
so that's one thing now when I started
um
my anxiety medication I read about with
onboarding of of a medication like that
that you could have sexual side effects
and that they at a certain point when
your medication leveled out
uh it would that would level out too and
I I did experience that so well at first
it was yeah it was like
I'm everything's taking longer it's
taking longer for me to get an erection
and then it's taking longer to reach
Climax and there were a few times that
I did find myself
uncharacteristically in my head about
whoa hold on is this gonna am I gonna be
able to pull this off and we're gonna be
able to complete the task here and yeah
that I could see how that would lead to
a downward spiral and just like
everything would fizzle out
um but
I also experienced this Middle Ground
where I was able to go longer and
so we had a different experience well
actually this is which was good that
that this guy mentions uh the blue pill
you know Viagra or Cialis and now just
just to finish my trajectory it did get
to a point I don't know how long it took
that it was kind of like
I'm back to how I was before I was on
the medication I don't I don't and
that's not necessarily
okay what I have heard from multiple
sources is that okay so one of the
reasons that we have this this
obsession with stamina is that a lot of
us get our ideas about sex from porn and
obviously the average dude in a porn can
like sit there and thrust with multiple
women in multiple holes for like an hour
and that is not what I and we don't use
the term normal but I'm going to say
that is not normal for me
um
but what I have been told
is that most of these guys doing porn
and to correct me if I'm wrong if you
know the the ins and outs of this is
that these guys are mostly all on ssris
and Viagra or Cialis
is one of the is one of the ways that
they're able to maintain that because I
don't necessarily think it's always the
case that first of all I don't think
it's bad I think that
I think that that this is a positive
side effects of ssris is in my opinion
if you could if it makes you last longer
as long as as long as you don't lose the
erection right
um yeah it was a good experience it kind
of opened up
um Yeah a different a different Avenue
and I'm not prescribing this I'm just
saying that this is an interesting
tidbit of like if you combine the SSRI
which you shouldn't just take ssris for
reasons other than to treat us you know
clinical depression uh you know a
diagnosis disorder from a psychiatrist
but it's an interesting thing that
they're doing both of those things in
some cases where they're giving
themselves the ability to go for a long
time without losing the erection because
of the Cialis or the Viagra and maybe
they're not just Super Troopers who can
go for an hour but maybe there's some
some medical assistance there two data
points for me I talked to my dad about
this on dispatches from Myrtle Beach you
know came up in conversation because I
was asking him he he said he's used it
and I was like yeah but why don't you
talk about the erection that lasts for
like 12 hours he was like that's four
hours that's what the ad says if your
erection at last for more than four
hours
um call a doctor
so he's
he he had some Success With It sex ass
oh I'm I've never used it and and uh but
I definitely don't think that there is
any shame in using it and I think that
uh when I'm talking about like some sort
of
Ed you know assistance kind of thing
right definitely if it the moment that
I'm like I feel like I need some I'm
making the call you could do it online
I'm I got there's no shame in that game
it's like again just like what a time to
be alive
I met a friend for lunch he's a friend
of a friend and we were kind of getting
to know each other
um you actually don't know this person
and
um
middle-aged guy and we were talking
about vacation we were talking about
like vacation sex or something and he
was like hey I'll I'll give you uh he's
older than us I that's probably he's in
his 50s
and he said you know what we'll schedule
a day and I'll I'll take I'll take one
of the pills and then we'll just
it's it's just he was like talking about
like it was miraculous like he could
just go and go and go and it was like he
so he was like giving me the inside
scoop he was like hey my only fear about
this because it isn't documented it is
documented that for some men
um
using that kind of assistance when
you're already healthy and you actually
don't need it in order to have
successful sex or you know to to
maintain an erection
uh can do something psychological where
you become dependent on it I'm I mean
I'm sure plenty of people use it in the
way that this guy is describing but if
it's just like oh now do I need I would
be worried and again it is documented
that for some men they they feel like
they've become reliant on it in order to
get it up and keep it up and so I've
just thought to myself
because I've thought about it this exact
same thing because I've heard multiple
people talk about this like hey you're
doing this anniversary weekend and
you've got a hotel or whatever bring
some Cialis along with you because I
think because one of them I don't know
one of them is like
hey take it now and you'll be ready in
30 minutes and one of them is take it
and you'll be ready all day like for all
day I can't remember which one is which
so do your own research
um but I the one that's like more acute
I've thought about that but the thing
that's kept me from it is this fear that
oh it'll be so good
that they're not going to feel like I'm
going to become reliant on it and then
you can have this psychological effect
where you actually do have trouble
because it's so mental I mean
maintaining an erection is such a mental
thing
um which again
personally with caution yeah and also
you know maintaining the stamina can be
a mental thing so one thing in addition
to changing it up it's like oh that
feels too good change it up you can also
just think about Richard Nixon
um you know you just picture tricky dick
you just picture someone that you're not
attracted to in my case that would be
Richard Nixon Like Richard Nixon
represents like
I there's nothing about Richard Nixon
that I'm attracted to now I I don't want
my wife to know that hey
you're having a great time I'm thinking
about
former president Richard Nixon
but hey whatever it takes to keep going
well I I would just be afraid to find
myself start to have a Nixon uh fetish
you don't want to associate your wife
with Richard Nixon yeah it hasn't
happened so far with me
all right let's hear another story here
hi Ren link
um I'm gonna keep my name out of this
because it's pretty embarrassing
um but I have a pretty weird sex related
story
um my ex that I was dating um
unfortunately for
about three years
um one time we had just finished sorting
the mail and we were cuddling
and he decided that it would be funny to
scoot up on the bed and uh pee directly
on my face
um
I
genuinely was so surprised in the moment
and had to have absolutely no clue what
was going on but um
yeah we broke up a couple months after
that so unfortunately I shouldn't have
done with him that long in the first
place but you know hindsight is 20 20.
anyways uh super excited for September I
love you guys bye what about the flying
hell
I'm sorry this happened to you I mean
consent is Paramount I don't I don't
besides that I'm I'm just a I'm I it
makes me angry and I don't want to talk
about this one besides that it makes you
angry
I mean I don't besides saying that I
have nothing else to say I mean
obviously this was this was a big No-No
uh
only because of the fact that she was
because the consent thing but let's
assume well let's let's talk about
peeing on people while we're while we're
here in this subject matter I mean
because I want to talk about that a
little bit I'll let you do that if you
want to but it's you don't have to
um
yeah I don't have any experience with
this this isn't something that I have
like I'm just saying like let's say that
this situation was talking about a
golden shower I was if the students have
a name if the story because some people
are into it and they consent to it
well you call it but you don't okay you
said it some people are into it that
sound a little Kink shame some people
are into everything I don't yeah so yeah
um I made it about consent uh yeah well
and so but I want to talk about this in
general though because if this isn't
something that has presented us now
again we've established before that uh
my wife has squirts I established that
on a previous episode and we know that
at least some of what's happening during
the score is it is urine there's other
stuff in there too it's complex not
completely that well understood but I
guess in that sense I have been peed on
in some some regard but it doesn't it
doesn't feel like that in in the moment
it isn't like hey right pee on me
because I want you to pee on me now if
you want if that's what you want that
that's what you want if that's what you
want you got to be on the same page and
if you are go for it go for it uh but I
don't see this being something that uh
I'm gonna a request that I'm gonna get
from Jesse for me to pee into her face
uh but you know what if she asked me to
I'd be like all right I this feels weird
and uh
but it says you want me to try it let's
try I don't even the thing is is I feel
like I might even be a little I might
get too uh gun shy in that situation
sometimes it takes a lot like I could be
next to somebody at an airport and
there's not a divider between the two
urinals and I have troubles letting it
go you know what I'm saying I I I get a
little stage from it I think I think the
psychology of this is part of the appeal
for those who are into it you know so
being able to just let loose wow you
know
obviously link really wants to move on
and now I'm gaining pleasure and not
letting you know
um read an email okay
just moving on
uh I agree consent consent yeah yeah
um he's he that's a shitty person
for real yeah yeah
but yeah if people like the peeing thing
definitely go for it have fun but that's
not cool
okay got a story uh
here's a good one uh the person did put
their name in the email well let's just
leave it I'll leave it Anonymous okay
dear messers Rhett and Link I humbly
submit the following story for a sec
September 2022 it's the story of my
first time with a girl she and I met at
my college dorm our chemistry was strong
so strong that we decided to take it to
my dorm room we're making out it's
getting hot and heavy you know the
meatloaf song Paradise by the Dashboard
Light yeah like that song but yeah okay
it was like that apparently yeah as I'm
about to sheath my penis in a condom
good suddenly my dorm's fire alarm goes
off it was it was like the stop right
there part of the aforementioned song
we both Panic grabbing whatever clothes
were on hand we followed the rest of my
entire college dorm outside into the
cold pouring rain of early March we were
both miserable for a minute but then
burst out laughing we've been together
for 13 years and we got married in April
of 2020. thanks for listening
congratulations another success story
I wonder if he unsheathed it first
okay I I feel bad about giving this
advice
uh but like 99 of all college dorm room
fire alarms are fake you know what I'm
saying like I don't want to listen I
don't want you to get burned up in a
fire and I'm sorry if it happens to you
but I'm just going to go and tell you
right now most of the time that's just
some Squad just pulling the fire alarm
for a prank
sure sure take that risk and no I'm just
saying if it's on you if I'm not giving
the advice I'm just saying if it were me
first of all I'm glad that it ended in
success and now you're married so you
worked for you but I'm just saying put
me in that situation I'm in a college
dorm not now
not 44 year old Rhett but back in the
day rep
and I'm and I'm sheathing it up and I'm
ready to go and then the alarm goes off
I think I'm gonna be like Hey listen
statistically speaking this is probably
not a real thing let's not stay out
Nicole let's stay here and screw
that's probably how I would have handled
it
let's make it quick this is exciting we
can actually do both at the same time we
could evacuate
and
what do you mean by evacuate evacuate
evacuate is like a term for like oh
pooping which again just like no
judgment ejaculate we can evacuate and
ejaculate if the consent is involved and
you want someone to poop on you all
right during a fire alarms
that is your right
hey Rhett and Link uh big fan Sean here
uh just curious uh have you guys ever
dealt with post-nut clarity
because uh
that that's rough it's a it's a rough
ride just immediately afterwards when
you you're done doing your thing
you just sit sincerity
just kind of think about life
so yeah I just kind of curious on that
kind of curious on how your personal
Clarity has changed over the years
so yeah thanks guys love what you do
peace post nut Clarity is not something
that I've ever heard named but my the
only way I relate to it in that like
I guess it's akin to like when you
ejaculate then it's just like there's
the Trope of I've totally lost interest
like or it's over like I can just roll
over and go to sleep or whatever I don't
know this is like this is a
well-established phenomenon but like
being sharper mentally no I I can
definitely relate to like jerking off
and then being really
um feeling really guilty about it
I've always understood this concept to
be is just like
I was thinking with my
other head and now I'm thinking once
again with my brain head and usually I
you hear this in the context of like
oh I was you know having sex with
somebody that I didn't really want to or
I was being driven by my
Sexual Energy in a way that then once it
was released I was like how the hell did
I get myself in the situation like
regret yeah and then in the context of
like porn if you picture like the
quintessential like teen who's gone down
a rabbit hole into some just you know
you're you're you're you're watching
like 80 Russian elderly ladies have an
orgy or something you you really weigh
down the the rabbit hole of porn and
you're and then you think to yourself
why am I watching this and how have I
got to this point right after you
masturbate that's how I've heard about
it in in in in but but I I remember this
as a team
especially as a teen in Purity culture
who thought that masturbation was wrong
and so then you would be like oh man and
now I see how wrong this is and I'm
praying about being forgiven suck it was
horrible that so that version of clarity
but I but this isn't much of a
phenomenon
as a middle-aged man at this point so I
don't think I I don't think I've been
like harnessing my post not Clarity I
think I've just been going to sleep I
mean I'm definitely gonna tell Christy
that like
sex makes me smarter for a limited time
yeah right so it's like that's some
that's that's something I haven't sold
it's hard to talk yourself into making
long-term financial decisions right
after you have sex but apparently that
would be a good idea let's hear this
story hey Rhett and Link I had an
encounter with a lovely woman I recently
met and we hit it off great had a few
dates and we eventually ended up at my
place and
basically the mail was going to be
sorted and she paused and looked at me
and specifically asked to not have her
socks taken off at any point
I obviously agreed and whatever but I
mean what's the deal with socks staying
on during sexy time
Jenna you're having a reaction to this I
I am I
from my viewpoint of it is is that she
perhaps uh hasn't had a pedicure in a
while or there's like uh an ingrown
toenail that she's embarrassed about I
don't see it as like there's some
practical reason that there's a
practical reason as you want to keep
it's cold just yeah or her feet get
extremely cold and she doesn't want to
like shock him with her freezing feet I
yeah and the fact that she said it's up
front like I don't see a big deal with
with the socks thing at all I find it
kind of sexy I mean I find it sexy when
a woman leaves her shoes on first of all
because if they're Knocking the Boots
because then it feels like an athletic
event it feels like we may be being
scored by judges you know what I'm
saying like if you got on shoes and
again I mean I think the sexiest thing
and this is probably like some um uh
unresolved misogyny is I love women in
high heels uh I'm working through that
uh but you know there's are you there's
there's sitting around working on there
I'm trying I'm trying to like naked
ladies in high heels less with every day
that passes uh but it is is it not a
sexy thing do you find it is it a sexy
thing when a naked lady in high heels I
just love socks man
um I love stockings but I do believe
that me it's not about the heel it's
about it's about the fabric up the calf
but I also think maybe I have a
disposition uh a bias towards this
because my wife is 5'3 and I'm six seven
yeah so heels actually it you know what
in my case women wearing heels is all
about Equity it's all about us being
closer to the same height
I just made it a very Progressive thing
uh but here's the thing
I kind of think that maybe like wearing
like some Air Jordans or something like
wearing some cross trainers wearing
something that makes you feel athletic
like listen if there is a fire alarm
we'll be the first ones out there both
of you put those kinds of shoes on and
maybe a headband in wristbands
gloves even things that make you feel
like you're going to work doing
something that matters anything that
like makes it different can be something
that can make it exciting a trucker hat
yeah and especially if you're getting to
know your partner and and they you know
you gotta acknowledge that this is a
point of um
putting themselves out there there's a
risk involved in saying hey I did you
know I don't want to don't take my socks
off be like you know what I love your
socks and I'm so glad you don't want to
take them off I got more socks we can
double up you want to put him can I keep
my socks on too it's like everything's
an opportunity to just get hornier yeah
you ever wanted just a belt like yeah no
yeah well I haven't either but it just
it's struggling let's just wear belts
look we just have belts on nothing else
yeah
I mean why not right how do you have the
best sex belt
like a utility belt a utility belt it's
got all the little vibrators and stuff
in there
would be like Batman up in there so yeah
I mean you wanna you wanna turn
everything into a turn on and when
somebody shares more of themself that's
a turn on double down on it don't don't
question somebody's uh
somebody's request if it can be easily
accommodated I mean you don't want to
put up any barriers you know what I'm
saying Jenna do you have another uh
email yes uh this story I have thoughts
on
um
here he goes uh are you ready for a
pathetic story my first boyfriend and I
had breakup sex he lasted 30 Wrigley
seconds then he got up farted
and asked if he could have my Diablo 2
account since I didn't like playing it
anyway
I said no then he left and we never saw
each other again believe in fairy tales
people
yeah well were all three of these things
related I mean maybe they're just all it
all just coincided short amount of sex a
fart that was unanticipated and oh while
I'm thinking about it Diablo 2. you know
we are grouping these things together at
least in the context of the story as if
they are related so maybe we just go
with that
yeah I just don't know about like tying
up loosens like ending a sentence in a
in an exclamation point but it's a fart
after sex I just
that's weird man I mean it's it's a
little flagrant it's a little flagrant
you know flagrant foul
don't bring farts in into the into the
bedroom if you can help it or unless
you're into it unless it's your it's
asked for
yeah
um what are your thoughts maybe uh I I
think he probably should have asked
about the Diablo 2 account before the
sex and farting or if he was asking
about it after I I think he should have
put in a bit more effort into the sex
part if he was going to ask this big
thing right yeah read the room man his
ex partner yeah read the room but yeah I
I think in if that was my ex that I was
having breakup sex with and that
happened to me I would think the
appropriate response would be
well
at least your farts last longer than you
do and then skipping like that is
dang that's hard to remember though in a
moment in the moment you're as good in
the moment you're probably him I think
in the moment I'd just be kind of like
um okay
it could be a text later a text later
break up no no immediately blocked I'm
like you know what I want to completely
forget this entire what do you do I mean
the whole not lasting a long time in in
for breakup sex that's not surprising
because if you think about it you take
enough for this guy no no no I'm saying
the step one the first step is I don't
think that that's where he went wrong
because what I'll say is I don't I don't
have this experience because I've only
had sex with one woman and we've never
broken up uh but if you if like my wife
goes out of town
or I go out of town and you get back
together sometimes that first reunion
you don't last as long because you're
super excited right yeah and so if
you've broken up with somebody and you
haven't had sex in a while like you got
and you hadn't like done the old um
something about Mary when you kind of
you know get one out of the chamber
before you get together
uh which I do recommend
um if you haven't done that you might
only last 30 seconds but in that moment
after you this is where post nut Clarity
really comes into play if you have
lasted 30 seconds
and you're like I think I would be like
Oh I'm sorry you're just so hot or
something like that you know yeah and
then if I had to fart
I wouldn't because I at least at this
age I still cannot fart when I don't
want to most of the time not everybody
can
and I don't play Diablo I didn't play
Diablo 1 so nope that block I just can't
at that point I just can't relate at all
I feel like the first step was you know
how he responded after that that first
slip up is where he started going wrong
after Jenna's comeback I got nothing to
add that was amazing I feel like it all
feels very intentional like he went in
knowing
it was gonna be short he was gonna do
something gross and then he was gonna
ask about some video game I'm not a fan
of this person no no yeah I think it's
good they broke up
wow
we can have one last
voicemail here oh that's not it right
down there hi retinolink I have a very
funny story in response to your
sextember Tweet
um about my poor friend when we were
babies in college we weren't literal
babies but we were very young people uh
18 or 19 and she had
sorry it's so funny
um never uh given a [ __ ] before and
she uh had started dating this guy and
they were about to you know go all the
way she could tell me all about and how
she wanted to try to give him a [ __ ]
that night and so
the next day I asked her how it went and
she's like I don't know it was kind of
weird I don't think that he was super
into it and I was very confused so I
said what what was he not into what did
you do apparently my poor sweet friend
uh took the
the name [ __ ] very literally and so
she you know went down there and just
was blowing cold air on his genitals
solid two or three minutes before he
finally was like yeah no we're not doing
that anymore they went on to go do other
things and my poor sweet angel friend uh
was horrified when I told her what that
what actually a [ __ ] entailed
um
so it was pretty funny this is why sex
education is important everybody uh and
that's all I have to say bye that's why
I call it a suck job you know you just
let's just get it let's just say what it
is
oh my gosh just I mean was it was a
story was there a distance there like
blowing from a distance or like total
like a total like get on it and then
blow it up like an inflatable yeah tube
if I was horny enough and I hadn't had
sex in long enough I feel like you might
be able to get me with just air you know
what I'm saying with like if it was like
that would be a Matic thing fun
precursor but like if you're if you're
latching on and then you're just you're
you're blowing I mean is it there was no
latching well that go to the urethra
will that go up to the bladder oh you're
saying hit the bladder explode if you
yeah if you blow it like that wasn't
what was happening in this scenario
blowing up a balloon you don't want to
do that yeah that can cause that can
cause a lot of issues
I totally thought
um that I I'm in that poor um girl's
boat I 100 uh yeah 100 percent thought
that a [ __ ] meant you blow on a penis
from a distance from a distance but but
uh yeah I don't have to answer this
question if you don't want fortified but
did you ever did you have a similar
experience or you just this was a
thought that you had
I had a similar experience you don't
have to answer it you don't have to
answer it she had a lot of embarrassing
things we're good we're good but yeah I
I uh yeah I I believe on my boyfriend's
penis and
um I thought that's what a [ __ ] was
and how did that what then what
um
it was very awkward thing uh
we moved on quickly to something else
right yeah yeah okay and um then I
learned later later that that's
incorrect he probably just thought you
were creative like I was creative we're
like we're just literally got something
new and she's got a different take
flowing around the area
I think I blew on his balls at one point
too okay yeah yeah yeah I mean yeah
you can blow anything you wanted yeah
yeah yeah like I could blow yeah yeah
it's like yeah I've got breath
I've seen a birthday cake before Florida
yeah yeah
I know what to do here wow
sorry do my jumbo okay okay but she is
not alone or that yeah that woman is not
alone been there
the fact that this was a story from this
woman and then
you had the same experience I mean this
is not an uncommon thing why is it
called a [ __ ] why why I even call it
that like I don't know it's like really
I just don't know I just don't know why
I can't of all the words that it could
have been that's the the phrase the one
out right
there's a lot of sex terms that don't
make sense yeah but this one is one that
just feels like a real real Miss
I mean fellatio is just a really great
name that's just a technical term
uh I don't know why why it would ever be
called a [ __ ] I guess because it's
like oh it's just my my
um it is explosive
I don't know I think you're making them
your mouth looks like you might be
blowing
you know maybe the first time someone
saw somebody doing it I was like I think
she might be blowing on this thing
uh I mean I'm not the one this is the
third party it was like an analysis it
was a doctor watching a video it's like
oh she is now blowing on his penis
uh he seems to enjoy it [ __ ] she
looks like she's working [ __ ] yeah
job
like no one wants to do it right right
that's the other part I don't like about
it like it should be a suck favor a lick
you know what I'm saying it's like yeah
it's not just suck you don't want to
suck too hard either I don't I don't
want to call it a suck favor
call it a uh
it's like a Tootsie Pop how many licks
does it take to get to this but if you
have to I mean you don't bite yeah I
don't know gently what's a word for
sucking on something with an intention
to lick on it not just to like suck on
it like I think there's probably a
German word for it
I think uh what about more of like a
sloppy saver
y
uh I don't know
we know we all know now I think we'll
just go with [ __ ] let's go we'll go
with blow job and just take the funny
stories as they come
wow I am I am exhausted
I am totally just I don't have a
recommendation well we don't have to
have a recommendation because we we
talked to two incredibly insightful
doctors who have incredible resources
you know we talked about uh sex with
Emily the podcast follow your books
follow them go for it Dr Emily nagoski's
uh book come as you are which we've
already wrecked one time in their book
that's coming do it again so just you
know what check out their resources we
have to tell you multiple times you have
to hear something you have to hear the
gospel 19 times before you make a
decision so uh you're hearing this wreck
multiple times
next week we're going to be having a
special listening party for a very
special is that it
is that it that is what we're doing next
right yeah yeah especially listening 40
40 for a special I can't talk anymore I
told you I'm just I'm burnt to a sexual
crisp yeah so this coming week special
project this coming week a couple of
things uh will happen uh actually when
you when you're hearing this my new
single give a damn just came out this
past Friday if you're listening to your
biscuits when it comes out uh and then
on the 23rd the whole album will come
out and we're going to listen to the
entire thing right here and here links
uh analysis of it yeah it's like a like
it it'll be a little listening party for
us come come next week in the meantime I
just will say you'll get more out of
next week's podcast if you listen to the
full album beforehand beforehand yo
James and the shame good point human
overboard 11 songs it's out there takes
you less than 45 minutes or so listen to
the whole thing and then we'll talk
about it next week uh in the meantime we
do want to hear your responses hashtag
your biscuits188 earpod one
foreign
link it's Amanda I love listening to
everything you guys do even as a lesbian
woman having sex with only her wife sex
Timber is something we both enjoy and
gives us a lot of uh new information
that sometimes we write last night
so thank you so much for doing all that
and thank you Jenna for adding a female
body uh into the information okay hi
Rhett and Link this is Trang long time
listener first time ear biscuits
participant you guys mentioned that
nobody has ever gotten sick from blue
balls before and I just wanted to let
you know that my boyfriend did make a
visit to the ER for having what I like
to call blue balls
um since he had free fluid in his balls
that were really painful and he just
rested for a couple days hey my name is
Jake I'm from Philadelphia and I just
wanted to thank you both get some
information initiation for mentioning
asexuality in the latest episode of uh
September uh I'm asexual and it's
something that you don't hear about ever
um really the only reason it took me a
long time to figure out is because you
don't hear about it so just even a small
mention like that means a great deal and
for you guys to treat it very
legitimately and not like there's uh
something wrong with the person or like
it's a medical issue is it feels great
hey guys uh this is Summer and I just
need to thank you all for
September like it has been something
that I've been listening to with my
husband and because of it my husband and
I have had the best sex of Our Lives we
were already open and talked about sex
before but it just created even more
conversations and I really think that
you you guys need to be thanked for it
and so thanks again for September love
you guys can't wait to listen to the
next episode
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]